welcome back black business month is
celebrated in august 31 days in 31 ways
and we have our way of applauding a
local black business woman here in las
vegas she's a lovely laguerre who owns
several black owned businesses right
here in vegas and she brought her mini
me ariana thank you ladies for being
here thank you for having us well you
both look incredible and we are just
chatting you know before the interview
we got some stuff to talk about ariana
but lovely i'm going to start with you
and you obviously have run a lot of
successful businesses here in the
community how do you support other
people who are interested in starting up
a business and where do you kind of take
them from start to finish i said if you
weren't looking to open your own
businesses always you know believe in
yourself and you know another thing to
do take action don't feel like you know
i don't know where to start but if you
take the first steps and be consistent
and you know you know align yourself
with other women other empowering women
you will find your way and you know get
coaches you know mentoring and you can
you succeed eventually in life yeah and
how has the support been in the las
vegas community for you and for the
other business owners that you work with
for me it has been tremendous i've been
very fortunate you know having the
success you know the support with the
she rises community and organizations
before i have different uh women that's
been behind my back supporting me every
day and uh it's been like you know um
almost like making a phenomenal woman
out of my business so i'm very excited
to have them you know align myself with
these women like-minded business it's
great yeah and you have a mini-me
following in your footsteps so i was
joking that i can barely read one book
and you have written multiple books
ariana tell me about your books what do
you write about so i wrote about a
roblox book and and you can change um
and you can change your avatar roblox
you can you can play games and you can
create games and roblox too and i really
like roblox and i play it a lot so
that's why i wrote a book about it and i
and i really liked it well i need to
read that book because i don't know much
about roblox and it is taking over so we
are thankful for you ariana for
explaining it to us and how does it feel
to kind of follow in your mom's
footsteps and do what she does she she's
really nice and plus that i love her so
much and plus and plus i love publishing
books with her and if i can publish a
book with her and me and her i can do
that that's incredible you have to be
such a proud mom right i mean it's just
like that's why we're like we're gonna
go together do a lot of workshops and
together it makes it more the bonding
more stronger even more and she's behind
everything we reading about the her full
books you know so
and doesn't that give you excitement and
hope for the next generation and you get
to help kind of guide them especially in
our community yes definitely and then
her her mindset behind writing her book
is to teach others to you know their
young kids to love to read and then her
goal is to like go out there and then
you know reading to them and help them
to like pick up books when they with
their parents you know at night and
that's what she writes about well that
is really special lovely and ariana you
both are so lovely thank you for being
here we appreciate having you guys and
las vegas now we'll be right back